bon ça ça va mais quand
[Musique]
twitter mon bébé
bébé
voilà
voilà c'est fait
doucement
quant au biberon oui à tout voir
et à tout voir l'empreinte je vais bien
deux heures toutes les deux heures
dans une nuit 2h du liban puis là je
n'ai pas changé je chante team
l'antipode il
je vais mettre en pyjama du coup je peux
voir bien oui sinon j'ai pondre mais des
couches qui est en plastique oeufs
pyjama tout matin quand il s'en va et
vient de sa couche
tout dépend des fois je le change on met
une propre puis des fois non des fois il
faut et repart avec quelques mois
suivant le ciel est mouillé ou pas il
vient tous les combien tu variable quand
il a le temps tu peux quand comme moi je
peux pas forcément le temps lontan qui
est bien fait pour nous en faisant et
demie m'ont aidé
le tout bois tous tiennent à un autre
qui va je m'attache au fait après puis
des fois je devais aussi des c'est pas
forcément les biberons des fois c'est du
pur et jambon ou alors des fois c'est
les petits pots salés pour l'acheter
l'adresse la tête dix ans quel âge sur
la carte d'identité est élevé entre 20
et 50 je crois que le plus jeune 22 lots
ou pluvieux 56 58
mais voilà si je le vaux si je suis un
petit peu oui il se rendort mais là je
vais mettre sur la table je vais être
déjà mort d'un bébé
jama ça m'a dit non ils font des grandes
tailles dont jouit parce qu'il y en a
quand même des fois qu'ils font avec 90
et que j'aimerais qu'ils ont fait sur
les yeux ou comme un chef
noront les faits sur mesure en allant
mesure où on a les gangsters qu'on leur
envoie un petit fascicule avec le tour
des fesses et des cuisses tour de
hanches trop des épaules enfin sous
toutes les mesures sont utiles
il faut une aisance pour la couche il
faut tout prévoir
tu mets
ab
ok
ça va aller
oui les couches sont faites sur mesure
aussi non les couches on nous achète
tout fait en magasin de pharmacie
incontinence ou l'autre mais sans fin
sont pas très sûrs
il faudrait qu'à trois fabricants et
l'idée d'en faire des couches bébé mais
adultes ouais aiguë qui atteint gibbs en
plus il ya un marché pour le broc palmer
monsieur c'est vrai que bon excellente
comme couche normale ce qui va pas quand
même moi j'ai centaines de bébés avec
quand même autour de moi oui moi je les
connais pas tous jeux dévoilés par
courrier je connais par lettre par
téléphone ou autre mais c'est tout parce
qu'il y en a qui sont mariés qui ont eu
ce qu'ils font c'est que leurs femmes
voilà du concert avec leurs mains des
gens qui connaissent leur sont proches
ouais vous verrez que tu vois jamais
quoi non il n'ya que je vois jamais sur
les sentes clients il m'a quand même tu
vois je sais pas je pense pas vraiment
d'un championnat
je ne sais rien tu sais pas ce que bon
je peux rester je poste un mois deux
mois sans voir personne parce que brosse
à disponibilité des gens c'est si le
temps qu'il faut et apple déconne puis
voilà j'ai du temps la guinée mais j'ai
du temps pouvait garder pouvait puis bon
des fois c'est l'après midi ce matin si
la nuit sans fonction ce que bon ils ont
ils ont un métier ils ont une vision ils
ont des responsabilités dont il a besoin
de choses comme ça donc ma fonction de
seube faut faire mais quand tu les quand
tu les changes comme ça a conclu en
tulle et l'enjeu n'est jamais un moment
où ça devient sexuelle il ya une
érection mai mais un bébé de trois mois
a direction qu'il ya trois mois une
réaction bon c'est normal qu'ils aient
direction parce que parce que c'est un
plaisir c'est normal le bonheur ça
traduit par un plaisir un plaisir c'est
une érection c'est logique mais bon ben
allal d'après lui la parole et l'action
s'arrête pas là
moi je suis le nouveau support
moi je suis là pour moi je suis allé
vers l'en but pour pouvoir
cette espèce de régression qu'ils ont et
leur faire vivre et puis bon ça me plaît
bien timbrée mars
c'est amusant c je suis pas ses heures
pour les adultes voilà septembre c'est
gentillet
c'est pisser c'était tout bleu taureau
c'est très joli mais vraiment une
nouvelle chambre d'enfant ouais bbb toi
comment j'en ai pas donc c'est pour ça
que je m'accrochais veut parce que bon
doigt une fibre maternelle qui est là
qui est latente est qui et qui me permet
quelque part de l'exploiter de
s'épanouir c'est tout donc c'est ça
maintenant peut-être bon peut-être que
je vais même aller chercher midi à
quatorze heures non ça va peut-être
qu'un jour j'en aurai bon peut-être que
je me tue près plus peut-être que je
ferais différemment mais pour l'instant
on sait comment elle a été amenée à
s'occuper de ses intérêts c'est un truc
tout bête un soir je faisais du minitel
comme ça parce que je connais le minitel
parce que parce que des fois c'est
pratique c'est un moyen intéressant des
fois de rencontrer des gens de voir des
choses différentes
et puis je tombais sur vie à quelqu'un
qui m'a tu m'a contacté qui m'a dit
qu'il était bébé broncher bien entendu
parler parce que j'avais vu l'émission à
la de chaval bon mais je connaissais pas
j'avais pas l'ange du beausset pas
d'opinion je connais pas je suis tant
que j'ai pas vu tant que je connais pas
je peux pas dire c'est bien c'est pas
bien vous pouvez débile ou alors de ce
fait on a discuté au téléphone
d'autres fois ci vous téléphone je crois
pas d'ailleurs c'est lui notre offensive
au téléphone puis après qu'est ce qui
s'est passé à y est venu chez moi avec
son petit sac avec ses ses pyjamas
barberousse ces biberons ces deux
couches et puisse habiller lui même il
s'est fait son biberon il s'est tout
occupé tout seul et puis j'avais je me
suis dit tiens il faut voir faut je ne
savais pas comment faire je ne sais pas
le prendre je ne sais pas je n'ai pas
donné le biberon c'est un petit peu je
connaissais pas trop c'est un petit peu
bizarre
et puis la fois d'après il est venu je
vais donner le biberon fed a prévenu gym
sa couche bien deux jours il a dormi là
il a passé la nuit chez moi donc j'avais
un canapé l'époque dans le canapé
et puis de fil en ligne
oui comme ça car il est installé un
petit peu oui parce que bon je vais rire
cette chambre basse et que j'ai fait une
association et puis j'ai association je
m'en suis je vais continuer comme ça on
est une association way qui est à lyon
et qui puis bon leur fait défaut mouture
relais barboteu les pyjamas leur
fabrique on a on a des bons à l'avancé
combien de gens qu'ils sont bébés
adultes dans les saucissons une centaine
donc c'est tout ça donc ça on a un peu
de contacts aussi à l'extérieur on a peu
de contacts la suisse la belgique c'est
maintenant 2 way cia qui les emploie ou
ses enfants en allemagne angleterre
c'est très répandu c'est très courant
aux états unis on a des minions j'ai
carrément l'opulence et puis bon laval
elle et les nurses passé quelque chose
de moi je veux dire de normal de rang
s'est pas autant ils sont très très très
pure est bon très très coincé les
américains être failli toucher de tout
ce qui est sexuel est très très bas
nîmes autant lenner c'est quelque chose
qui était un ami du naturel
mais toi quand tu quand tu fais je suis
pas content avec un homme t'as pas c'est
un réflexe de t'occuper de lui comme ça
ou pas appel dans ma vie dans la vie
sexuelle non non je fais l'amour
normalement sinon je suis pas ta pas
tendance à en fait pas une formation
professionnelle en effet pas cotée
mattern maternelle avec le bain avec
l'homme qui avec le bébé moi c'est bien
deux choses différentes et 1 db il ya un
homme c'est bien segment avec un
hambourgeois relations cette enchère
s'est passé ici battant qui sont
l'association mon général c'est un peu
je veux dire un peu compris dans les
prestations condamne donc on leur dit
bon c'est bon signe à cet aspect les
follicules ya les couches et le lait il
ya le biberon les petits pots les choses
commencent à parler des petits pots de
nos la bringue
le sait bien c'est du pipeau
oui un petit pot de chambre ah oui un
petit peu de gens de chez soi ou plus
je l'aï dit exactement je trouvais ça va
remplacer mignon et voila voila il veut
changer la fumée quoi tu me tues mais
pas te mets une crème âge oblige attaque
mais je suis mais du talent je mets de
la crème jeu mes produits je vois un
coup de pub produits poupine à un
paupinat mais voilà depuis mais au final
on saura pouvait venir voir c'est bon ça
marche bon quelques plastiques break le
plastique pour éviter les fuites
passion
en général ils en parlent à leur
entourage leur femme ghana women allons
y en a qui dit qui fin qui laisse qc
dénicher un continent yann acl haïti le
vivant secret total
ouais puis bon mois la mission demande
pas trop ça me regarde pas comment ils
vivent servir
moi je suis là pour leur bulle pour
molière fantasmes ce qu'ils vont les
jambes les avantages et les avantages il
ya comme tout le monde mais je sais pas
je veux pas savoir civile ce à quoi ils
le vivent habituellement je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui peut être assez
lourd à porter et je sais pas moi je
peux encore aider tag mois quand ils
arrivent ici ils viennent ils sont bébés
leur affaire de grands elles sont sûres
dans un coin de la pièce ils les voient
pas et c'est tout et l'otan qui sont là
ils sont bébés le reste du temps que les
femmes qui viennent des fois non moi
j'ai pas de femmes il y en a mais moi
j'en ai pas mal acquis et il y en a oui
il a très très peu de femmes et un jeune
âge je pense qu'elles sont pas vraiment
bébés sont je pense que c'était
peut-être petite fille pas bien je sais
pas bb c'est pourquoi
voilà je crois je pense que c'est
peut-être plus le fils par rapport à la
merde merde que tu
donc peut-être sein de ce côté du monde
ça va merci c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
chez une nounou enfin de vente
ben non pas de ça devait être prédestiné
il bosse plus jeune j'avais même quand
j'étais petit bah si tu t'attaques c'est
une grenouillère problème avec lui
enfin si tu vois ta taille
je viens de matter courtage même des
couches peut même pas tombés d'accord
pas un problème
c'est un boulot non non c'est que c'est
pas tellement évident parce que bon
encore lui c'est un petit modèle quand
on tombe sur quelqu'un qui est un peu
grand un peu balèze soir matin mais
ferme m 1,15 120 kilos et des kilos pour
le changer c'est pas facile pourtant
général ils ont ils sont enfin moi tout
ce que j'ai rencontré d'un côté je vais
pas dire ça se voit mais presque ouais à
la mi temps où ils ont les hutus trop
ils ont un petit côté vraiment bien son
récent mais voilà il un côté enfant à
côté bébés y ait un côté bon vin c'est
un peu je sais pas pourquoi c'est
marrant parce que moi je prends le train
et je regarde les gens maintenant dans
le train je maintiens peut-être s'offre
un bon oui mais voilà tu vas dire je
viens suicide
bien qu'il est bébé tète du kiné c'est
bon je pense qu'on a tous y aller c'est
qu'il y avait tellement qu'ils doivent
avoir envie de le faire et aux parts et
si bien qu'en plus ils croient qu'ils
sont tous seuls
j'ai retenu dubé lettres ou des coups de
téléphone en dix ans mais je crois que
j'ai dit tout seul comme ça bon c'est
vrai qu' de chavannes a fait un petit
peu que ça bouge que ça on en parle mais
c'est vrai ils ont tendance à dire bon
ben moi je suis dans mon coin tout seul
un peu isolée peu perdu mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya peu à côté de ça bon c'est vrai
que c'est gentil c'est pas comment je
veux dire c'est pas ça n'a rien de
dégradant ça n'a rien de temps à vivre
comme en extérieur comme ça on comprend
pas trop le plaisir et qui peut y aller
non mais bon j'ai des gens qui ont des
iden plus bien que ça et qui limite on
trouve ça logique entre sa plus normal
il après tu vas avoir couché ouais après
je ne couche c'est encore un livre blanc
et puis après il dort une langue depuis
un premier bon bah oui
[Musique]
c'est bien haut
croire
mais ne pleure pas muet les foires qui
chouine mais la première fois que les
garder la nuit moi je n'y croyais pas
trop s'en sert de bd samedi ça mais
c'est un peu ces petits et la première
mise donc il à rester chez moi je laisse
courir d'années et il faut il a chuté
comme un bébé
tiens vraiment à vraiment un bébé à côté
de moi et c'est vrai que le sida lui est
bon il fouine un petit peu il bouge un
peu ça fait un vrai bébé réel
et puis bon c'est chez le bébé c'est la
pluie position bbc tout le temps très
naturelle on sent bien que c'est pas en
plus souhaite tout ce que j'ai eu moi
qui sont restés à dormir je suis couché
de bonne heure puisque bon je leur mets
4 biberon ses arguments dans la nuit
dont le bonheur donc l'emea au lycée 9h
9h30 une espèce de des clients leur tête
parce qu'une fois qu'ils aient le
biberon de dos ils sont au lit y dorment
même si c'est quelqu'un qui me dit moi
je me couche tard je la fais tarbes
rigueur je suis pour veut biberon le
lient l'homme sasso mais que c'est beau
bébé
bon ça mange ça dort on fait des câlins
je savais dans une couche savent même
pas encore empirer du tout c'est bien
beau temps bon côté
parce qu'en général les mamans elles
veulent toujours qu'il enregistrait vécu
un vrai hein je pense moi je suis comme
ça je pense que j'en avais eu j'aurais
qu'il en serait donc la sortie quand
c'est bon ça va bientôt on va le laisser
dormir
j'aimais dans son mini bon dodo aller
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus